Hey whats up guys? I'm out on the Oregon coast this week with my wife, we're camping and we just got our tent set up.
So I thought it would be the perfect opportunity to show you a cool little trick you can do with one of these soda can tabs.
So here's the deal guys, when you're setting the fly up on your tent you may notice these strings with these little black tabs here.
And at first they don't seem to serve any purpose.
But if you take one of the loops and loop it down over your tent peg and then pull it tight
And then pull it tight grab that little black piece and slide it up
And this acts as a tensioner to put tension on the rope and keep everything taut. That's especially
Important if you're camping in Oregon where it rains a lot because you do not want your fly to touch the side of your tent
Or else moisture will get in when everything's pulled away properly like that
It'll keep the wall of your tent separated and keep all of your belongings dry inside
But what if your tensioner breaks or gets lost like on this string?
I don't have one that's not really that big of a deal because we're gonna solve the problem using this soda Tab when you got
your soda can it's very important to keep this [center] part on the way that you do that is you rotate the tab all the
Way around until the top part is facing into the hold and just press it down with your thumb
It should pop out with that center tab intact if it is then your business and the rest is pretty simple
I've taken the tab and just push it forward a little bit
So it creates a gap and now if you take the string from the back you can push that through the gap and pull it
all [the] way through
now the rest is [just] as simple [as] basically tying a knot to the bottom of this tab and that's just going to be a
Simple Overhand knot
I'm just going to do one turn and pull that tight and as easy as that
We've got our homemade tensioner now when we go [up] the line and pull back
It'll grab on tight, [and] [if] we want to release we just pull this back, and it will slip all the way down
Let's try it in real life and see how it works. I got the tent peg down here
So now we just take that loop around our tent peg grab the tab and just pull it straight up
Just like that our homemade tensioner is working
And it's working really well if you want a little bit more attention
just grab the tab and push it up a little bit higher and you can see that when it comes back it digs into the
String and holds its position
[and] you can apply this trick to almost anything you can think of where you need to apply tension to a line like maybe hoisting
Some food off the ground to keep it away from Bears or maybe making a clothes hanging line to dry out your clothes [now] obviously
This isn't a permanent fix
But it's a great little hack to get you by in a pinch so there you have it guys
That's a cool little camping hack using materials you probably already have around the campground anyway
Hope you enjoyed this video, and we'll see you guys in the next one. Talk to you then